this is a production of cornell
university
thank you marcia well it's really nice
to be here and that this is uh
first opportunity i've been able to
really talk with my colleagues here in
the horticulture section
and then sips wider about kind of some
of the work that i've been most involved
with over the past
uh 10 plus years so this presentation's
titled action research and reclaimed
places partnership development for
community horticulture projects
and i'm really focusing today on how you
can
learn a little bit about the process the
participatory action resource
research process as a potential tool
for working in community-based
horticulture projects
some of the things that we're hoping to
talk about again and have a little
discussion about at the end of this
presentation it's really understanding
the participatory action research
process as a tool again for partnership
development projects and grants
demonstrating some examples and lessons
learned from some of the
action research projects i've worked in
in a community horticultural
setting and then really applying those
tools and resources to new york state
so um as marcia mentioned i've worked in
non-profit contacts for a national
nonprofit culture
force which basically did a community
environmental action process with youth
and then i went on to work in farmers
markets
as well as working with the city of
savannah so i have this diverse
background
and i've worked in many areas of the
country and i've applied basically
the same process to project development
in those different communities
so i've learned from different contexts
and different settings how this how this
works
how how it can be improved and i'd love
to share some of that with you all today
and even though we normally uh in
cornell garden based learning really try
to do
more interactive presentation style i
will be waiting until the end so if you
have questions i'll have some pauses
during the presentation so
please feel free to put those into the
chat
and we'll address them definitely at the
end of the presentation
all right so this is the basic concept
around learning by doing
participatory action research i actually
first learned about this
at cornell over 10 years ago with the
cornell urban scholars program
and par really draws on a wide range of
influences
among both professional training
programs as well as those who draw on
more of their life experience
and public education so many of the
concepts i'm talking about draw on the
work of paulo frierry
and adult education research as well as
the civil rights movement
and key initiatives like the
participatory research network
created in 1978 in new delhi
so the basics of this i really wanted to
break it down a little bit
essentially each piece of this
participatory action research process
engages community in different ways the
participatory piece first starting with
that word
really we're talking about engaging in
collaborative work with community
partners
not necessarily bringing research to the
community partners but developing
questions with
community members and so this is a more
as opposed to kind of more
maybe traditional research methods it's
more about
empowering and engaging communities and
developing questions and
addressing issues through their own
solutions
with those same community partners the
action element of course is where people
actually create
real change um in their communities and
this is really
where also we'd like to see real
outcomes
in terms of the interventions that are
provided
and then the research piece is of course
key so when we're reflecting and
learning about how this
intervention went we really want to know
how does this build on our past
knowledge how does it help the community
take those next steps forward towards uh
solving the issues in their community i
love this quote too this is just a
really helpful quote i think around
sustainability in general but
this kind of education and research
process
sustainability is better seen as a
measure of the relationship between the
community
as learners and their environments
rather than externally designed goal to
be
achieved and that's really key so we're
working on again developing that
relationship with the environment
with people in that same community
instead of providing solutions
so it can be certainly a messy process
at some points
but it really works with how adults best
learn
people learn through that active
adaptation of their existing knowledge
in response to their experiences with
other people
in their environment and that is what
social learning is all about
i really like this diagram because i
think it really
helps to show how community change using
this process
is really a long-term process right so
it's not
it's not a one-and-done kind of
situation um
really this process starts with a
community inventory of issues and
strengths right so
for example if you're interested in
food security issues in your community
the
the engaging with the real world setting
situation might be actually doing a
um a walkabout of your neighborhood
identifying locations that might be
potential community garden locations and
really again focusing in on that issue
of
how you want to address it in this case
with the community garden
the planning and action intervention
stage that's really where
you've taken this policy and practice
research into an actual
setting of clear goals and objectives
and developing a
detailed action plan and then of course
next step is implementing the strategies
and developing
and actually taking action in the
community
with the diversity of partners and then
evaluating and reflecting on the results
of the community groups involved
and sharing that back with the community
so how has this benefited for instance
food access in the community in the case
of a community garden
and then of course as you see again this
is a process that you can do multiple
times
um on a number of issues so if you're
talking of again this community
gardening and food security issue
you might address one year establishing
a community garden
potentially finding another issue
related to this
that you wanted to build on and and you
would take this process again
in developing more community solutions
to the issue at hand
i want to just touch on briefly um this
participatory action research process
within the context of high quality adult
learning methods
so this is definitely something that we
preach a bit
in our cornell garden-based learning
programs but it's so important
most of my life most of the work i've
done in community-based settings
in government in environmental education
has all been with adult learners whether
they be
k-12 educators or neighborhood
association leaders
so with that context in mind we really
need to think about
educating for the public in a very
different way and so
much like working with young people
there's a real focus on against
experiential learning and for adult
learners that can be building on their
life experience so you really want to
again
uh touch on the experts uh in
communities right they're experts in
their own lived experience and really
touch on that with the kinds of projects
you develop and
and engage them in um you need whatever
project
that you're developing to be relevant
and impactful to the learners lives
so again we're most interested as adults
in
developing something that's going to
actually positively influence our
neighborhood
our community and our our lives
and then the problem centered piece of
this project
based learning is really all about again
addressing an issue right that comes
from the learners the adult learners
themselves
and having it be again impactful to
their lives
and of course being involved in that
process is really key so in
participatory action research
we're involving adults in developing the
questions and addressing
any issues with solutions that they are
really helping to generate
so to make all this possible we really
need to have
some key things in place right we need
to understand adult learners motivations
and goals we need a safe and trusting
learning environment
and we know that adults are going to
know about 85 of the information we come
up with
or you're planning to share so
remembering that and understanding that
what we
what we see what you see today for
instance you'll probably only remember
about 30 percent right
you'll remember about 50 of a
demonstration and 70 of what
you simulate and then 90 of what you
actually do
so that's where really participatory
action research and action projects and
communities
are so powerful they uh assist the
learning process for adults
and then we're actually doing something
that we can then retain the information
a lot better
so i'm gonna tell just a few stories of
um how i learned about this process and
why it's been so powerful in my
my work working in community-based
environmental education
and sustainability work so i first
started again
learning about this process through the
cornell urban scholars program
which originally um when i took the
course again it was a summer
program an eight-week program in new
york city um ken reardon led that
initiative throughout the
year before and trained us in the
process
and then we were paired with a partner
and in my case it was uh
roger hart at the city university of new
york who works in
children's environment research and that
was the area of research i was um
i was involved with in my graduate work
so i really loved applying
this methodology to this children's
environments and specifically
children's gardening spaces and in the
case again
the context of new york city the gardens
that i researched and worked in
were in the lower east side many of them
had been developed when the city was
in that part of the city particularly
had long term and disinvestment there
was a
large movement of gorilla gardeners
really the project green thumb
originated in new york city
with some of these thriving gardens and
vacant lots
in the lower east side and again now
there's this pressure for development
in this part of the city and throughout
the city for many of the gardening
spaces
so one of the reasons i was paired up
with this particular researcher
was to kind of again defend the need for
spaces like these
for natural children's spaces in the
city
there's a lot of research and benefits
for nearby nature for
for young people from both concentration
and
mental health to just a physical
activity and cooperation
of children and learning social skills
so i actually conducted
kind of a behavioral analysis of
students and i'm sorry
more young people and families in these
garden spaces
in comparison to some of the more
traditional playgrounds
and so that research again was kind of
my introduction to participatory action
research
but it really in the context of
everything else that i've learned since
then
it really has helped to spur a lot of
the research and
interest areas that i've had um going
forward
and one question i'd just love for you
all to reflect on and think about is
what are some of the other community
health benefits of gardens
um in the face of climate change and
this pandemic
i think there's a lot of a lot of things
that we could
potentially research in community garden
spaces
in the future that we haven't tapped
into as much
i'm now going to jump forward uh a
little further along
to an example in savannah georgia just a
few years ago
so i worked in savannah georgia in the
sustainability office and as a
neighborhood services coordinator
i went to a lot of nightly meetings and
engaged a lot of people about what they
most wanted to see in their
neighborhoods
and a big common theme throughout lots
of our neighborhood meetings
was the need for community garden spaces
that could be sustained
again having resources and funding
available as well as really sustainable
volunteers
and so this became a big part of my job
not only helping community gardens get
the resources and partners to make them
more sustainable but also engaging in
kind of this process of understanding
um what makes a sustainable
vacant lot into a into a gardening space
and so i did a number of things to
assess that
with community partners and neighborhood
members
i became involved in the savannah urban
garden alliance
and engaged a number of environmental
partners in the community
to do a green infrastructure
professional development for
um like many many of these various
community partner organizations to kind
of get us all on the same page
around what are the needs for green
infrastructure in this
coastal flood prone community
uh we did a vacant lot nursery study and
really assessed
what could we use these lots for even
alternatively
beyond just community gardening spaces
and so we really looked at
how could we potentially use them to
raise trees
that could be used in city planning
efforts
and then finally we worked with a youth
group to do a pilot
tree planting project with the community
partner savannah tree foundation
so this was really the whole assessing
the needs stage again that kind of
observing what's happening
engaging community partners and
organizations did a lot of surveying
of i would say i think 12
neighborhood associations about what
they really wanted to see
and that really laid the foundation
again for developing this partnership
network
that would help to create a new grant
program through the
southeast sustainability directors
network grant all focused on again
flood prone communities communities that
are very impacted by climate change
and in the case of savannah when i was
there they had two hurricanes that
didn't do as much damage to buildings
but did some terrible damage to their
pretty famous tree canopy so trees and
flooding was very much
on the top of mind for many people in
this community
and basically as a result of this what
we what we came up with
in this green infrastructure initiative
grant was
a grant to fund sustainable landscaping
and arborist training because
many community members we had to
actually hire outside of the city
to get arborists um to come and and
support
uh city uh tree planting and maintenance
efforts
we also were replacing like i mentioned
trees following two hurricanes
and we're looking for a more productive
use of vacant fema lots which cost the
city
thousands of dollars to just mow every
year
um and then we also were trying to add
small community supported green spaces
so some of the trees that were in the
nursery were intended to stay in these
lots
as long-term pocket parks in these
communities
so in the end we ended up with these
partners
and i've kind of put these similar
stages here to kind of help you
understand some of the different stages
of that par
process with the partners in play
so we really observed again using
mapping technology using gis
noaa sea grant data and uga helped a lot
with this
and really evaluated where were the
plots the fema lots that were
basically flood prone could never be
built on and where were they also
overlapping with areas that had a high
unemployment
and basically a low-income community in
savannah
so we found three specific community
garden sites where we already had some
relationships developed through the
community garden alliance
and we partnered with victory gardens um
again to assess how much would it cost
to really
put in some um long-term sustainable
um vacant lot tree nurseries
in these uh nearby plots they're just
again as a as another use for these
slots
so we evaluated like i mentioned these
vulnerabilities and assets in the
communities
and um after doing that pilot study we
really convened the partners
and and now since then they've been
implementing these three small scale
nurseries
um in green spaces and they're really
successful
and have had a lot of really positive um
interactions with other community
partners beyond this as a result
and so some of the community events that
they've been able to do to reflect on
this process
have have involved sharing results and
evaluation factors back to the funders
about the success of this program
so i'd love to just take a moment i know
that
i've talked a lot so far i would love
any um
any comments or reflections on what i've
shared so far
about how you gather community partners
around a common research mission
or objective and really what projects
we're already doing in horticulture that
might be able to be
better supported maybe by this kind of
methodology and neighborhood-based
resilience in new york state
so i see a lot of potential in this area
not just in urban areas but also rural
and suburban
so i love any thoughts that you have on
those two questions and really just
wanted to give folks a minute or two to
think about that
and then i'll carry on
this is a picture of some of the
students implementing that pilot project
i talked about
looks like somebody raised their hand i
think what if folks want to put their
comments and thoughts
into the into the chat actually i think
what we'll do is
is just um we'll have a little
discussion at the end i think that's the
way we've
kind of been asked to run this so
we'll definitely get to any questions
you have at the end
i'm going to share one additional
example of participatory action research
and this is in the context again of use
of working with
youth in southeast michigan so this is a
fantastic organization called the
southeast michigan stewardship coalition
that's mission is completely based
around place-based education with young
people
in the metro detroit area but
essentially um
most of the work with this partner was
also educating other adults again
educating other educators on a process
for kind of
breaking the paradigm of of education
and having students engage with
community members in addressing issues
with community-based problem solving
and ashley i'll just alert you that you
do have a question
okay okay all right thank you i'll
answer it um
looks like uh the question is is there
any effort towards promoting food trees
oh very good question chestnut trees are
a really good source of nuts and need to
be planted more anyways
just wondering what types of trees are
being raised in the nursery um that's a
great question
and this is again um we'll we'll get to
a uh more of a solution to that question
we actually did look at that and it
ended up not being
a great fit again for the the city's um
the city's needs they're looking more
for street trees
not as much food growing trees even
though several of the community
gardens in savannah actually grew
peach trees and kumquat trees and other
things like that but
these were more kind of the adjacent
community garden lots
so we did do some of the fruit tree
planting and some of that again with
more of the lots that were
affiliated with the community gardens
but with some of these more tree nursery
lots
um that wasn't really the focus it was
again more looking at street trees
so um i can pull up i've got to pull up
the report to get the
the list of of trees that we that we uh
we're recommending and again they've had
um a number of iterations of this since
so i need to do a little follow-up with
the folks there and find out exactly
what trees they've chosen but they had
to be flood prone
um well but they had to be trees that
could um be okay with having like wet
roots
which many of the trees in savannah are
but again they had to kind of serve a
couple of purposes
does that answer your question and we
can talk a little bit more about that
too
um so
uh and again i really am excited about
sharing these with
with you all because um again i come
from a social science
background and i've done some research
and done a lot more research and learned
a lot more about
trees in the urban landscape but i'm
really excited about working with
partners who can bring that kind of
level of
expertise to this kind of work and this
is something we're in develop
we're developing for cornell
garden-based learning as well
and again when i talk a little bit more
about this example with the southeast
michigan stewardship coalition
the people that are organizing this this
organization are really the university
professors that are are getting in touch
with the content experts
and resource experts that can help the
students and
educators create action projects so
that's kind of the beauty of this
is that um you don't have to be the
expert in all this you just have to know
how to build the partnerships
and bring the experts to the table that
can work with community partners
so in this case i'm just going to give a
little bit more of an
example here um one year they do a
different theme for professional
development every year
and this was all about climate
resilience so they're very i think
topical to
what we're all dealing with this year
and really worked with students and
educators across veteran detroit
to look at great lakes integrated
science and assessment data
and really some data from the city of
detroit's sustainability office
to understand again at neighborhood
scales how students could contribute to
formal sustainability and climate
resilience planning initiatives
so the students and their schools were
obviously distributed throughout this
the city of detroit as well and we're
involved in a community environmental
inventory
of great lakes climate impacts on
detroit and then planning some
resilience projects that could be again
learning
kind of labs for the students at those
schools as well as addressing some key
issues
in that community so all year long
the southeast michigan stewardship
coalition provides professional
development
to its educators in this network on this
topic
and so it preps them to work with the
students using this data
and then really engages them with the
community partner approach
so after looking at the data in detroit
students would then be paired up with an
ecoworks
americorps member part of this this
organization that really develops
resilience projects in detroit and
worked on stormwater management tree
plantings and household response plans
for things like heat waves so they
developed action projects that really
addressed some of the key issues in
lower income neighborhoods in detroit
and as a result of that they then worked
with michigan sea grant partners again
working with that university connection
to get funds and work with reflecting
back to the noaa environmental literacy
grant program
the data and results of this this grant
so it was kind of
similar in some ways to the way we work
at cornell garden-based learning in that
we
are working on developing professional
development for our educators
which in our case happens to be
community horticulture educators
and then we ask for evaluation to help
us feedback that feedback loop of how
are we doing
are we addressing the real needs in your
community um are we creating things that
you need
to do this work and so it's a it's final
the final piece of this program that i
love is the sundays community forum
they bring all the students and teachers
together to
eastern michigan university for
basically a community showcase of their
projects
so they get to share back not only with
other educators
but with with their peers about what
they've done and how it was successful
and then they build on that year to year
with new topics um through the coalition
it's a really great model and i just
love some of the resulting projects
so i am going to kind of pause there and
i'm thinking
um now we're going to transition to our
second objective which was to
look into the community mapping tools
that can be helpful for you
developing some of these projects in
your own communities
or maybe in your own research i'm just
going to double check the chat it looks
like we have one other question
folks working in ithaca saying it's a
little bit difficult to balance
volunteering
with local communities and being a
student in search of a career
how do you engage people in local
communities and what types of groups
people do you target
this is a great question for this
section particularly because
it can be incredibly messy and
challenging to
work in community work it's definitely i
just want to acknowledge that this isn't
simple it's complex and so it really
takes
doing an assessment first and working
with building that trust over a couple
of years
and in both of those cases that i've
talked about those community
organizations have
deep roots in that community and while i
was a facilitator of writing grants and
bringing people together
the partnerships that had a strong
connection and
a sense of community in themselves were
what made them successful
and so i'm going to talk a little bit
about that and why it's so important
but that these are kind of some of the
tools for assessing both your
vulnerabilities
related to where you most want to work
on these kinds of community horticulture
projects as well as
what kinds of organizations do you want
to engage
and build trust in to do this work with
you
because as a again as somebody at a
university
you know or a local government you know
it takes a lot of energy and effort to
really build that trust
um with local organizations and so like
i said it takes time
um and as a student it can be it can be
difficult for sure
but working with those right partners
will give you that foot in the door to
be able to work
work really effectively on these kinds
of projects so in the case of savannah
i'm going to use this as an example
using these tools we use the social
vulnerability
index through the u.s climate resilience
toolkit again remembering that we had
a sustainability plan we had a
real focus effort on figuring out some
key areas to work in
in the city and so we were able to look
at with this tool a mapping tool
where are there flood-prone communities
that also overlap with
low-income um you know uh
communities and there's a lot of these
areas in savannah because it's a
low-lying coastal city affected by
by sea level rise so we were looking
not just at that we're looking more at
like where are the flood-prone
neighborhoods that also happen to have a
lot of these female lots
obviously that we could potentially
do more of this job job training piece
and so that was that tool was really
helpful for really
focusing in on three specific
communities that had strong neighborhood
associations strong connections
again already had this great
neighborhood
cohesion and had a lot of
buy-in to this kind of work and that's
where again the assets come in so the
asset-based community development
getting back to that question
is an incredibly powerful tool that has
been utilized in savannah
for a very long time and i learned this
when i got there i learned about this
tool it's through depaul university but
it's a
very very good community-based
development kind of tool to look at
when you're thinking about what
community partners are in a community
already
which ones kind of best align with our
mission or our research objective for
some particular project or program
and then it also has some even some
interview tools for finding individual
strengths
so again as you'll look at this diagram
you'll see
there's local institutions associations
and individuals so i'm going to go in a
little bit more depth
about what this looks like i just
put up tompkins county here for
reference using that same climate
explorer tool
again this is a tool that i didn't add
the uh
the key here but the very dark blue
areas are areas that are both flood
prone
so have that as a potential climate
impact in that community as well as
have some social vulnerability
factors also layered into that map so as
you can see the dark blue areas are the
areas that are most impacted by both
and this is just an example of a way
that you could help to prioritize
what community what part of the
community might we be doing projects and
that would help us
to address multiple issues at once other
tools i would also suggest using for
other kind of goal areas like food
security
and ecosystem services i tree has some
amazing
um capabilities for telling where there
are where there's a lot of tree canopy
versus not a lot of tree canopy in
relationship to
to income levels in those neighborhoods
and there's also a usda food access
atlas that can tell you where there's
access to grocery stores
and that kind of a thing so if you're
looking at those other factors
you might want to look at different
mapping tools for assessing this
and then getting back to the assets i
think let's say listing
really for gardening purposes for
horticulture purposes
what are the individuals associations
institutions
and physical spaces available in your
community
to address one of those pre-existing
vulnerabilities
that we talked about and so that's
that's the way we
we've we formulated some of these grant
programs around kind of these two areas
assets and vulnerabilities
and then just to kind of wrap it up i
wanted to share
a few of the common project partnerships
that we've
again when i say we i'm talking about
the city of savannah's sustainability
office and my work
with a national nonprofit there was you
know very much a
community engagement process that looked
at what kinds of partners should we
be engaging effectively and these are
the common ones with the organizations i
mentioned
noaa and secret has an amazing amount of
resources
specifically related to resilience and
cornell has a fantastic
program in that in that regard as well
local government sustainability and
planning offices are often really really
partnership focused
and very community-based focused in
their responses
community gardening organizations
obviously i've had a lot of success
working with them in the past and
projects because they have a real
ability to unite people
from across the whole region in this
kind of work
but then when you actually get to the
action part not only are you working
with the neighborhood level
neighborhood associations governments um
you know agencies that work in this area
you might need some additional kind of
hands-on action project partners so
these are folks like garden education
organizations
um tree planting organizations and
watershed organization organizations and
my experience have been
kind of the top three for this kind of
work um
and we've had a lot of success again
engaging them
in in this kind of project then of
course
working with university extension or
local public schools
that added element of how do we evaluate
and share the results of these projects
long term did they work did they not
work this is where
extension can really play a really key
role
so lessons learned um i wanted just to
share a few key takeaways
that i really think we can then apply um
to our local context to our statewide
context in new york state
what i've found in a lot of the best
partnership
arrangements we've had a lot of really
wonderful diverse partners with
different strengths and skills like i
mentioned earlier
you can't possibly have all this
knowledge and background to effectively
create a community-based project
we really rely on content experts but
also on community experts so from their
own lived experience
people who are going to be benefiting
from these kinds of projects need to be
a vest have a vested interest from the
get-go
and problems always arise right so in
the case of some of these projects we
had a
number of hurricanes we had budget cuts
there's a lot of things that come up
so it's really important again to think
about from a sustainability standpoint
the you know three-legged stool
so having multiple funding streams for
economic sustainability
having in-kind and support of
organizations that
that are aligned with your mission for
instance the city of savannah providing
free access to these fema lots was a
huge
asset that we that we took advantage of
and then of course building on the
community momentum
and interests and so i think again there
was a lot of activism around
planting trees at this time when i was
engaged in savannah
and specifically for neighborhoods that
were surrounded by
industrial uses they really wanted to
see more tree plantings they wanted to
see better air quality
flood control so everybody it was a
win-win for a lot of people
and that's kind of the last takeaway is
that when developing these kinds of
community-based action projects i've
really found that finding elements that
that support a number of the
stakeholders um
their i guess their strengths but also
you know what they
what they have a stake in their
interests um
you know really is key so in the case of
the savannah project we had
job training we had a reduction in the
city budget
we had replacement trees from the
hurricane we have you know a green space
for communities
that really wanted them so there was a
lot of partners that benefited all at
once
so i'm going to take a little pause
again i'm trying to slow down but not
not too much i want to have some
conversation at the end um
i'm going to transition into the third
part which is just how does this apply
to community
horticulture projects specifically in
the context of cornell garden based
learning working with our
cornell cooperative extension offices so
i'm just going to focus on briefly
two programs that are ones that's
already been developed and has a really
great track record
called seed to supper which is our
essentially our curriculum a beginner's
guide to
low-cost vegetable gardening but it's
really about partnership and community
building
and then a new program called the food
forest trial garden program which is a
little bit more on the
um i guess community food forest kind of
side that we talked about a little bit
earlier
so just to reiterate again see this
supper
is a really again complex community
based program that involves a lot of
steps
essentially we provide a curriculum
and a six course
six course uh series that we helped to
get
educators prepared for um statewide
but we really are providing again kind
of a community-based model for this so
it's very unique in every county that we
run this program
it first starts with getting a satellite
partner which is our cornell cooperative
extension offices
and they host essentially this program
often will apply for our mini grants
they then
work with us to advertise to community
participants and also getting garden
educators which are
our volunteers many of them happen to be
master gardeners
and we put them through kind of a garden
education preparation
every winter and sometimes
when we have a student course which we
do this year we engage cornell students
in actually preparing the educators
across the state
and then finally those same garden
educators
work with host agencies like
neighborhood associations
like current community gardening
associations
food pantries many different partners
that already work
in the food security arena to implement
the program so it's a great model for
again how we can kind of build these
partnerships
and there's an evaluation of of our ctis
for participants
before and after the course to see how
that's really helped to shape
their gardening experience and
you know their ability to grow food so
there's a wonderful kind of
again model already set up here in new
york state for this kind of work
um and there's there's a new program
that i'm working on developing with a
number of community partners and
statewide partners called the food
forest trial garden which i'm hoping to
build on the success of seed to supper
sites
really adding an element of climate
adaptation education
and food security education to that
program
so we're hoping through this program
again to develop a series of advanced
master gardener volunteer training
topics on ecological garden
and so this is a neat area we found
through a lot of surveying and a lot of
work
with with partners we have a community
horticulture work group through our
sustainable landscapes program work team
we're developing kind of this network of
experts on this particular topic
or across the state and we just had our
first meeting
and have been reviewing our cornell
garden based learning library course
which is our
master gardener training to see where
are the gaps what are some potential new
areas we could be educating people on
and and like i said we've done a number
of these surveys
with partners across the state and
looked at the feedback we've gotten
and here's some of the next steps that
came out of that
we have a couple of advanced topic
courses that we want to add again to
our core training based on the feedback
that we've gotten
water management again rain gardens and
xeriscaping
are a big area that master gardeners
want to learn more about
soil health and depth and climate change
and plant selection are huge
areas that got a lot of a lot of votes
from other participants in the course
as well as integrated pest management
specifically bio control
and then of course the design principles
behind how to really apply these skills
in a
specifically a food forest trial garden
which is a demonstration garden
and master gardeners across the state
understand this and
this is really a concept that many
cornell cooperative extension offices
even here at tompkins they have a great
demonstration garden area where you can
learn about it a lot of different
gardening techniques
so this is building on kind of advanced
whereas we have our seed to supper which
is beginning gardening
this is taking it to a next level with
more advanced training
for these master gardener volunteers and
as a result we're hoping to have a plant
selection list that can be implemented
in a second and third year so the final
piece is here
in year two and 2022 we'll host a
demonstration site installation again
getting that experiential learning for
our educators across the state
we'll provide in year three a mini grant
program that will take the
the resources developed and the plant
selection list
and share those with our educators
statewide in cornell cooperative
extension offices
so they can implement their own small
scale
demonstration site and my hope is also
that we can add to the research and
evaluation elements
here in the horticulture section like
the woody plants database we're hoping
that maybe there's some very successful
plants in these gardens that we could
add
to that database as well
so finally we're kind of wrapping up
here i would love just to leave some
extra time for folks to ask questions
but um the food forest trial garden
partners has kind of talked about at the
beginning
the partners helping out in this initial
first year phase of
assessing are the sustainable landscapes
pwt
and some new student hires with
landscape architecture and horticulture
background
we're working with key counties that
have experts in this area
um cce tompkins and schuyler and tioga
steuben
we're hoping to then plan and engage
them along with master gardener
volunteers
in an implementation workshop of a food
forest trial garden site
and like i said evaluate the education
and learning that happens as a result of
this
that can then feedback to on the
horticulture section
and uh these are just a few of the
really fantastic partners that we're
interviewing and talking to about future
workshops
but um we have some really wonderful
people working in the state
i get to work with all these wonderful
folks and i'm really hopeful that
we can get some input from all of you
all so i believe
i'm at time and i would love to
open up for our question and answer and
hear what you have to think about
um participatory action research is a
method for this kind of research in
community horticulture
all right i think i'll open it up
anybody ask me i actually um
thank you so much for this awesome talk
uh it
reflects really well i'm taking this
climate change and human development
class right now
in dsosh and um so i noticed that you're
speaking especially in all of these
community-based projects
it's within the critical discourse uh
surrounding climate change where
a lot of like government agencies i've
noticed in businesses especially
they operate more in the biophysical
discourse where it's more about
okay this is the problem that's
happening to our climate this is the
solution that we're going to
use and it more focuses on economic gain
so i was wondering um within that how
you see kind of moving forward with
these programs and how
because you have worked with government
organizations especially on the local
level
so how do you see transitioning that
into more community involvement
and and kind of bringing that more into
the mainstream in the future
yeah no that's a great question because
honestly um
working with local governments exactly
you're completely right i think
um what's really challenging about it is
it's mostly about the bottom line
um and i think for a lot of local
governments again they'll do a carbon
assessment
they'll really like they'll see where
their largest you know
potential um carbon
you know issues and and they'll really
focus in on that more on a technological
piece but
from a perspective of again resiliency
all that
the literature and the um the best
practices really look at
how do we engage people in in developing
some of these resilient resiliency skill
sets
and so i think that action research and
this kind of work again it has to be
integrated into planning so as you saw
in the examples
in savannah we had a sustainability
planning effort that preceded this
right so there was a large effort to
survey and engage community neighborhood
associations to find out what did they
find most important what do they won't
want to do
and that influenced and informed the
plan we had the right political backing
at that time to do that
and again they had all this prep work in
this asset-based community development
work that
all the neighborhood associations
apparently went through extensive
training on this method
to develop neighborhood associations
over 40 in the city it was a huge
effort and they have a ton of very um
again
a very tight-knit community-based
network of
organizations that work with
neighborhood groups
throughout the city so it's very unusual
it was a very unusual city
to work in in that way because i think
it had this groundwork
for that kind of um and they had they
actually had a ton of uh
positions at the time for neighborhood
um
basically neighborhood outreach folks so
i think that's one way that we can
better
do this is that in in bigger cities
again really having
dedicated people like i the role i had
um
where i would be going out and going to
neighborhood meetings and
engaging directly with neighborhood
leaders
and we need that kind of hands-on
building of trust
in order to i think again translate
what's happening more at a
at a city government level with trying
to reduce carbon impact
to how does this really relate back to
my life like how does this relate back
to how it will impact me and i think
that's where the public health folks
are really helping out a lot with that
with a lot of these mapping tools and
kind of
practices at educating community members
about the impacts of climate change on a
very local level
and the way i was able to work with some
pretty pretty
um i would say regressive sorts of
policies
around things like green infrastructure
was to really just talk about flooding
we don't even talk about climate change
we just talked about flooding
and we talked about how it impacted
people's lives in a very like real way
and that bought in that really got a lot
of community buy-in
which then added to that kind of
political pressure
plus getting money doesn't hurt if you
get money from grants to do this kind of
work
it really helps i hope that answers a
little bit of your
of you guys thank you so much
um
is there anybody else who has any other
questions because i know there's a lot
of great experts and i tried to
again put a lot of information in but um
wanted to have more of a discussion
again about how this relates to
to your own work or against it for
students their interests
um if this is something that folks want
to learn more about and again partnering
with other disciplines like urban
planning like landscape architecture i
think there's a lot of
potential to really be
integrating both the plant sciences and
the social sciences so thank you
i have a question for you ashley can you
hear me
yeah um i in in trying to do and sort of
involve
people in participatory action research
have you found
or um have you found that um
it takes a while sometimes for
volunteers to understand the principles
of doing this and i'm sorry if i missed
this
discussion oh no no no no and and
honestly i didn't really
i think what one of the challenging
things about doing a seminar like this
is because
it's you know normally when we do uh a
workshop
in seed to supper um you know we really
first ask questions about the audience
and kind of get a sense of where people
are coming from
and so um that would be like that's
really again
where the volunteers um and again in
many of the communities
where i was working in savannah there
was not necessarily like a huge
environmental bent
um but really more of again um a social
justice bent to a lot of the
neighborhood organizations there
their leanings so
i i really found that to get people on
board with this i didn't talk about
participatory action research i really
just talked about
um you know here's some key areas that
we're hoping to look at
citywide to influence health and
sustainability
and we talked about like kind of these
five key areas and one of them happened
to be
more green infrastructure though we
might have used a less jargony term
um at the time and so really describing
to people
why this would be beneficial people get
community gardens pretty
pretty quickly because it's like we'll
have food and it's like
this is something people want they want
more community spaces and they want more
you know accessible food healthy food um
so that
those were not as hard of a uh i think
the buy-in wasn't as hard as again kind
of describing why we needed
um more trees in the city and why
they're so beneficial
and that there's different cultural
feelings about trees
in different areas related to safety
related to
all kinds of things that you might not
normally think of
so i think once people got and again i
have some really
really great kind of article i can share
that talks about some of the
the impacts on some of the local
community members who then got trained
in the full
kind of arborist training program um and
i think
they really show how the benefits of
this community
project speaks to the community again
when it was
all about job training and helping
people to start their own businesses
um there was an incredible amount of
buy-in from these communities that were
you know looking for looking for jobs
looking for opportunities so this is
something that there really wasn't a lot
more of in
in that part of the state or really um
there really were no organizations doing
that kind of work already unlike here i
think there's just
there's just um we're not like
we're not green infrastructure projects
going on so it was new
and it was providing economic
opportunity and so that was i think the
biggest
most positive way that we were able to
also then generate
some um from a volunteer perspective
also getting a lot of volunteers engaged
in from the communities to to reach out
and get people involved in the training
program that was
that was huge any other
any other questions
well i appreciate everybody um coming
out today and if you have any other
questions feel free i can put my um
email in the chat and feel free to reach
out for more information
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu